when you think of las vegas fine dining
leserk at the bellagio is at the top of
the list and the restaurant just
reopened and joining us to tell us more
is executive chef damian evers
congratulations on the reopening thank
you thank you now you are at the helm
you are running the show and tell us a
little bit for those who don't know
about the restaurant the cuisine that
you serve and why we're so excited that
you guys are back open again
the cuisine is um
just a contemporary modern french same
as before but a little bit more of a
modern twist and now that you're hidden
here i'm i'm guessing you're putting
your own touch on things and you you
have something one of your signature
dishes one of the many and by the way it
smells like truffle in here and it
smells delicious right now what what are
you going to show us today right now
we're going to prepare um a beverage
it's considered like a panna cotta it's
a cauliflower beverage and on the top is
a lemon vermouth
verbena jelly oh my gosh okay that
sounds incredible first of all and i see
this caviar i've never had caviar in my
life i i'm very excited about this so
okay how do we how do we put this
together okay first we're just gonna get
a nice
helping of caviar now this is green and
typically i've seen like black caviar
yeah this is essential okay sour
imperial essential caviar from
petrossian
do we do a nice little cornell put that
on
top like that wow
how would you describe the taste of
caviar for someone who's never had it
very sweet briny and succulent okay okay
that sounds good we have um petite
basils we have lemon verbena
and we have lemon balm
and a little bit shiso for flair
you're all about the flare everything
looks so beautiful here um as you're
putting that together can you tell us
about some of the other dishes that are
here up front this one looks like
hawaiian kopachi sashimi it's our
sashimi course with a built-in chip with
aromatic herbs
red shiso
and the red little twill a little thing
right there is our um
uh fresh on chili with meyer lemon that
looks absolutely incredible okay we're
uh we're getting done with this one can
you tell me the name of it again because
i want to say it right
this is our caviar with cauliflower
lemongrabino
lemon verbena is a herb that we get from
one of our pervaders
and that beverage is like a panna cotta
oh okay all right so now if people want
to check out lester now that you guys
are open again at the bellagio one of
the best views in town
for sure how did they get in there
uh you can make your reservations on
online
or um i think it's online you can make a
red
reservation yeah i definitely make a
reservation you want to get in there
what is this black thing that you just
missed our our school our nori buckwheat
chip oh wow i mean this is a work of art
it truly is can you get a shot of this
devin
this is look at that i'm afraid to mess
this up can i taste it absolutely okay
so how do you how do you eat this i want
to get the perfect bite
here's the caviar spoon okay a little
bit of caviar and a little bit of the
cauliflower cauliflower and the lemon oh
my goodness
this looks amazing
okay here we go first time caviar
oh that is sweet oh my goodness this is
delicious i taste the lemon in there wow
and this is one of the many delicious
delicious cuisine that you could get
over there i'm going to keep eating this
is so good thank you so much and
congratulations on the opening gotta
check out for more information
on the circ visit the bellagio's website
at bellagio.com